>> Greg: DO A GOOGLE SEARCH
FOR -- GOOGLE'S WORK WITH
PROJECT MAVEN.
GOOGLE HAS PULLED OUT OF THE
PROJECT UNDER PRESSURE FROM
THOSE WORKERS.
APPARENTLY DOING ANYTHING
CONNECTED TO THE MILITARY WHICH
PROTECTS THE LIVES OF THOSE SAME
PASTY WORKERS ARE GOOGLE'S VAN
FOR THEIR BRAND.
GOOGLE, YOU KNOW IT IS BAD FOR
YOUR BRAND, YOU.
YOUR MOTTO USED TO BE DON'T BE
EVIL.
IS AND WHAT YOU JUST DID KIND OF
THE OPPOSITE.
YET WHILE DECIDING NOT TO HELP
OUR MILITARY WITH THEIR AI, YOU
INVEST FORTUNES INTO OTHER
COUNTRIES AI.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING
TO DO WITH THAT?
D-DAY BEING YESTERDAY, THAT'S
THE OPPOSITE OF GOOD TIMING.
I'M NOT GOING TO CALL YOU
TRAITOROUS.
YOU ARE SCARED.
YOU ARE SCARED BECAUSE IN THIS
DAY AND AGE COME AMONG YOUR
HELPING UNCLE SAM IS HELPING THE
OPPRESSOR.
OH, YOU LOVE THE WEALTH BUT NOW
DISMISS THOSE WHO ENABLE AND
PROTECT IT.
HOW REMOVED YOU BECOME FROM THE
IDEAS YOUR PARENTS AND THEIR
PARENTS AND THEIR PARENTS FOUGHT
FOR.
THE DECISION GOOGLE MADE IS ONE
OF COURSE THEY CAN MAKE.
BUT IT'S FOOLISH AND HARMFUL.
AS DRONES BECOME AN INEVITABLE
PART OF THE DEFENSES, AND OUR
ENEMIES OFFENSES, GOOGLE MADE A
CHOICE.
MAYBE WE SHOULD DO THE SAME.
DANA, IT DRIVES ME CRAZY.
IT'S HARD, YOU CAN'T SAY I'M NO
LONGER USING GOOGLE.
BECAUSE THEN I'M GOING TO GOOGLE
OTHER OPTIONS.
BEING.
DOES THINGS TO WORK.
>> Jesse: I USE ASK JEEVES.
DOES THAT STILL WORK?
>> Dana: GOOGLE IS A HUGE
COMPANY.
IT'S NOT JUST A SEARCH ENGINE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT ERIC SCHMIDT, HE IS ON THE
DEFENSE INTELLIGENCE ADVISORY
BOARD.
BECAUSE HE IS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT, ESPECIALLY WITH CHINA AND
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS AND
WHAT IT COULD DO TO OUR FUTURE.
IF YOU WANT TO BE SAFE AND
PROTECTED AMERICA, THEN YOU
PROBABLY SHOULD HELP OUR
MILITARY.
>> Greg: SCHMIDT IS NO LONGER
THERE.
THEY ARE SELLING STUFF TO CHINA.
THEY ARE WORKING WITH CHINA,
GOOGLE.
>> Jesse: I AM AFRAID TO
CRITICIZE GOOGLE BECAUSE THEY
MAY LEAK MY SEARCH HISTORY AND
THEN I AM TOAST.
>> Kimberly: WHY DID YOU SAY
THAT OUT LOUD?
>> Jesse: IT IS A WEASEL MOVE.
YOUR HELP IN THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
YOU REDUCE CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
DEFENSIVELY, TERRORISTS ARE
GETTING ACCESS TO DRAWN
TECHNOLOGIES.
YOU WANT TO DEFEND THEM AGAINST
THAT.
AMERICA, IN A SICK WAY, IS
ALMOST TOO SAFE.
WORLD WAR I, WORLD WAR II,
THREATS WERE EVERYWHERE.
DOMESTIC ATTACKS, PEOPLE ARE
GETTING SHIPPED OVERSEAS TO
FIGHT FOR A COUNTRY.
WE ARE SO FAR REMOVED FROM THAT,
WE DON'T HAVE THE SENSE OF
PATRIOTISM AND NATIONALISM THAT
WE USED TO.
WE CAN AFFORD TO LET THESE
THINGS LIE DO NOT PROTECT THE
NATION LIKE IT USED TO BE
PROTECTED.
>> Kimberly: WE NEED TO BE
MORE WORRIED ABOUT CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER IN TERMS OF AN
IMMINENT THREAT OR ON HIGH ALERT
ABOUT SOMETHING TO SAY WE REALLY
DO WANT TO DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO KEEP OURSELVES SAFE, LIKE
AFTER 9/11.
THEY HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL TO BE
ABLE TO SAY I AM OPEN TO THIS
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
DOES NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
SO THEN IT RUNS THE RISK OF TIME
PASSING, MAYBE PEOPLE BECOME
COMPLACENT AND HE FEEL TOO SAFE.
>> Greg: THEY ARE A BUSINESS.
WE TALK ABOUT BUSINESS CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THE NFL CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT.
GOOGLE CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT.
THE NATURE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
DESIGNED TO REDUCE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
WHAT CAN BE THERE ARGUMENT OF
THE THEY WANT TO BE APPEARING
PC.
>> Juan: IF I TOLD YOU I WAS
GOING TO INVENT SOMETHING THAT
ALLOWED FOR CONSTANT
SURVEILLANCE BY ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, I THINK GENERALLY
GREG WOULD SAY NO.
>> Greg: I WOULD BE FOR IT.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
I WOULD HAVE DRONES IN MY HOUSE
IF I COULD.
>> Juan: IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Greg: I MIGHT ALREADY.
>> Kimberly: LITTLE DRONE MAN.
LITTLE DRONE MAN.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE IDEA THAT YOU
ARE EMPOWERING DRONES TO HAVE
THE KIND OF FACIAL RECOGNITION,
BODY RECOGNITION.
YOU THINK WAIT A SECOND.
WHERE IS PRIVACY?
WHERE ARE MY RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS AS AN INDIVIDUAL?
YOU CAN SAY IT MAKES OUR DRONES
MORE EFFECTIVE.
I THINK IT STARTS REALLY, HOW
WOULD YOU SAY, ESCALATING.
THE BAD GUYS GET IT AND SUDDENLY
WE ARE IN TROUBLE.
THAT'S WHY I THINK, SO YOU ASK
ME.
IF IT'S ABOUT MILITARY, I AM ON
YOUR SIDE BECAUSE I WANT OUR
MILITARY TO BE STRONG.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE IN THE
MILITARY'S HANDS.
I DON'T THINK THAT.
>> Greg: IT'S GOING TO BE IN
SOMEBODY ELSE'S HANDS.
>> Dana: THE CHINESE
MILITARY'S HANDS.
>> Juan: THEY DON'T HAVE THAT.
>> Dana: I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY
CAVED TO 4,000 EMPLOYEES.
>> Greg: MAYBE THEY SHOULD
RETURN TO THE CAVE.
THERE IS NO GOOGLE IN CAVES.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT